[Music]
happy three by
tuesday you tapped into the nba finals
edition
of the group chat live in the bleacher
report app presented by fanduel
it's uh it's crazy how loud the sun's in
four chance were when phoenix went up to
nothing
but you can imagine how loud the bucks
in sixth chance
will be tonight inside of pfizer forum
arena my name is cabbie richards
dropping back to back 40 point
performances with her picks
that is aaron dolan and the vivious
member of the crew he's like our drew
holliday who's from cali he's from the
bay area
salute to greg ivory welcome to you both
[Music]
hello all right so uh listen milwaukee's
won three games in a row
totally turned the series around tonight
is game six
of the nba finals in milwaukee g-money
what do you got for the people
hey we've been giving away free kicks
and all of our shows
and i'm not done i'm not done we're
giving away
up to 5k in sneakers
today and we're giving out six a total
of six
aaron six cavity six six six that's
where you from
uh six 250 sneaker gift cards to put
towards whatever kicks you guys in the
audience
want i'm giving out three pairs
right here on the show i'm giving out
another pair
on vr betting social another pair on the
br
app and i'm not done i got another pair
on br kicks i like to start the show off
with an
alley oop to somebody in the audience so
get in the comments and
tell us what kicks would you buy
like what what if if i was to give you
some money what kicks are you going out
there
to go purchase right now and i'm giving
out a pair
of kicks to a lucky fan who gives me a
interesting take hold on greg before you
do that i don't know if you saw this on
br
kicks but on sunday they posted this
video from pj tucker
giving away a pair of sneakers to an
assistant trainer
michelle yeah this is dope i mean pj
tucker he is
the sneaker god three years in a row
he's won
the sneaker guy title from br kicks hey
salute to pj tucker such a good dude
uh aaron if you haven't picked up a pair
of ones like michelle just got
uh what what's in your summer rotation
so i have some off-white kicks
some kids shoes i love bajas as well but
honestly i keep it all white during the
summer
got to keep it fresh and got to keep
them clean too you know and uh
be wary of the crease in the toe but
anyway uh
gmo like i listen i'm here on the west
coast i just picked up a pair of vans
and when i'm on the east coast i
kick i stick to my ultra boost and the
j's
g money you're a west coast dude do you
are you about that van's life or what
oh no you you picked up a pair of
balencies the other day didn't you
uh not he had caviar you know i had to i
had to go
grab some valencia's i had to go grab
some valencia's the other day
but the yeezys just came in the mail the
yeezys just came in the mail
wait these are stuff i wear them
no no no no no the mono the the the mono
the yeezys they're not the slides
they're they're actually the 350s
g-money did you get to go to that
listening party the other day here in
vegas when you're here
ah nah kanye kanye kanye didn't send the
invite it's all good next time we got to
put it together
yeah we got to put it together it's all
good
hey but i'm in the comments though i
they're they're listing off a whole
bunch
of uh of takes in the comments let me
just
say a couple of them i got uh
ant lost rookie of the year he says the
taxi 12s
he's rocking with the taxi twelves i got
deep geek
deep geek is in there he says the aj
ones can't go
any other way oh i think he's saying the
ones the jordan the one
yeah yeah shout out to you d geek
cabbie uh i think it's time
i i i think it's time uh to give away
some sneakers and i have
hold on just a second just a second i
have nameless
nameless is is shouting out nike not yet
nameless nameless now yeah nice got a
pair last week nameless
was no no no he's not correct on the
comments yeah he's not winning this week
he's not easy
shout out to you namaste you're going to
get a hoodie shout out to you but i got
down to earth down the earth
i need some university blue ducks
switched it up here cabbie didn't go
jays didn't go lebron's
you know what i'm saying we went we went
dunks we went to those
north carolina colors right i think
that's i think that's what those are
i think so the university blues shout
out to my guy
uh shout out to my guy down the earth
you are walking away with the first
250 dollars in sneakers money okay well
listen
he came from the heavens and now he's
playing on earth the greek god
has been has been responsible for two of
the most memorable plays in the nba
finals
a ridiculous block on deandre jordan in
game four
and then in game five finishing the fast
break in alejo and the flex
the greek god is on when giannis
antetokounmpo has been activated
uh we asked you in the app and on social
how many points
is giannis scoring tonight in game six
check out the little sneaker rotation
right there see some j's in there i see
some air max 90s
but anyway i know the comment section is
filled with different takes
the line is 32 and a half points greg do
you think giannis will have his way with
phoenix's defense
tonight and what do your people think
captain with the winners only army
let me ask them let me ask them cabbie
what i need you guys to do is get in the
comments and tell me how many points
giannis
is putting up tonight at the end of the
game will dmu will dm
one person who gets the closest and
hooked you up
with 250 dollars and sneaker money aaron
you predicted the sun's in six
predicted the sun's in six if the suns
are to win game six do you think giannis
is going to go
over or under 32 and a half points
so i'm going over here regardless of the
outcome giannis is averaging
32 points the nba finals so far so far
34 points
in milwaukee remember he had that one 41
point performance
in game three giannis also hit over his
points for up 50
on the season so with that said it's
also game six they had the chance to
obviously win the nba title tonight i'm
gonna have to go over 32 and a half
points
for the greek freak prop tonight
this this feels like it should hit but
there's
so much more pressure on milwaukee
tonight to win
on their home court uh but regardless
they've been a handful
they've been like five other players
who've all had great games in the series
and it almost feels like
almost that giannis is an afterthought
we marvel at devin booker's
back-to-back 40-point games we're
marveling drew holiday's defense chris
middleton is the closer
but um and there are also people out
here on the media talking about giannis
being
the robin to chris middleton's batman
stop it
okay let's just stop it that's
ridiculous the closer comparison
is shaq and kobe where shaq carried the
lakers for three quarters and then kobe
took over in the fourth
giannis carries the bucks for like three
quart
three and a half quarters and then chris
goes to work
in that final five and he's been
electric but giannis
i know he he understands this moment you
know
as i mentioned the great kobe bryant who
tweeted a few years ago
you got your mvp and the next step is
the championship this would be an
incredible
prophetic win for both kobe being bryant
and yana santa tecumpo so with that said
give me
33 tonight for giannis 33 points
14 rebounds and an emphatic win bucks in
six
let's get it giannis gmoney are you on
the same same page
as aaron and i will we say the over
tonight for the greek god
cavi before i give my take you already
know i
gotta tap in with winners only in the
comments before i tell you if i'm with
you and aaron or not but
they are in the comments the comments
are jumping i got
bad sports takes says he's having 37
points
with 12 rebounds four assists shout out
to you
bats exactly you're walking away with a
hoodie
real exact real exact uh here we go
wade0821 says 35 points the finals mvp
with 11 rebounds and five assists
shout out to you wade0821 you are
walking away with the hoodie i'm giving
out one more hoodie
one more hoodie i have
spicy dubs spicy dubs he's going over 32
and a half for sure
at least 35 he's gonna take over tonight
he's averaging
more than everyone right now shout out
to you spicy dubs
you are also walking away with the
hoodie
cabbie aaron i'm right there with you
guys
giannis has he's a man on the mission he
is a man on a mission he's been playing
really well uh scott foster
is the referee tonight cabbie okay yeah
it's tony brothers yeah chris paul
usually
doesn't you know win when scott foster
is the referee
so i'm filling the vibe we're killing
the vibes that giannis is gonna have a
big game
tonight because there's gonna be some
controversy on the other side
you think so he's owen 12 when he's
refereeing in playoff games that's the
way i
hey that's a fact right there cabbie
that is a fact what aaron just said
so i'm rocking with giannis man listen
but scott brothers has been a referee
for many many years and has refereed
thousands of games guys so it's not just
like
chris paul i know obviously i feel like
this is the twitter chat though today
all over yeah it definitely it
definitely is
happening theorists are out tonight did
you see did you see the report that the
nba put out
did you see like the actual the crew
chief
the crew chief is scott foster
yeah yeah he's the he's the top dog so
he's he's calling us
you're talking about tony brothers no no
scott foster
is the crew we're fine there's tony
brown always well also
he's also a referee listen all right
we'll we'll see how it goes
but remember what i'm gonna eat the
people in the comments though remember
to drop your takes in the comments
after the game we'll pick one winner who
is closest
to take home the 250 in sneaker cash
but we also got two more pairs to give
away in the show so cabbie
let's keep this thing going all right
salute to spicy dogs again is
getting a pair of kicks is the avatar
and spicy dubs like the jameis winston
like the moment where he was eating the
dub remember that a few years ago
random reference it just made me think
of that spicy dubs um you guys know that
we love our quick
hitters around here and so does the
fanduel chain legend
john doe dropped 10 bands
on a race to 10 in game five and my guy
hit
18 000 on a race prop
i mean the payout is amazing but imagine
having 10 bands to drop on a race to 10.
i love the confidence and uh salute to
john doe we've seen him many times
on on br betting social and we feature
them a couple of times in the group chat
has a huge fanduel chain out there in
brooklyn new york um
but listen that's legit race to 10 the
tenney one of our favorites
our favorite though is the the three by
two
this is a and it's being boosted by our
friends at fanduel for the three by two
parlay which is quite simply will there
be two three pointers made
in the first three minutes of the first
quarter and two three-pointers made
in the first three minutes of the third
quarter parlaying the first half and the
second half together
plus 410 that is juicy in game five
the bucks and the suns combined for 27
three-pointers
and both teams shot over 50 you know
these teams can light it up from
downtown
unfortunately only one leg of the three
by two hit in game five
so we need a bounce back game tonight
fanduel is offering the boost and we
just saw the odds plus 410
uh both teams have hit 53
three-pointers through five games we got
to get it g-money uh who in the audience
is riding with us today cause i'm
already i'm just singing right off the
top i'm locking in the 3x2 parlay
love those vibes cabbie love those vibes
let me see if those vibes are
transferring to the audience in the
comments
what i need you guys to do in the
comments uh
get in there and tell me if the 3x2
parlay will hit tonight and most
importantly tell me
which players tell me which players you
think
is putting the ball through the hoop for
the 3x2
giving away 250 in sneaker
money to my favorite take aaron do you
think we're gonna have a bounce back
game tonight
yes of course i mean last game these
teams were on fire from three i know
this in cash but still
the buck shot 50 from behind the arc
well the sun shot 68
so for that reason i'm absolutely
locking in like cabbie the 3x2 parlay
tonight
like i always say great value and you
just have to take it
chris middleton andrew holliday are in
their bags right now both are getting
huge praise from the media
and they know this is their final home
game of the season
brook lopez needs to redeem himself
though he's been playing
he's been underwhelming at home he's
went one for nine from downtown in games
three and four
in milwaukee and he's normally a solid
duty normally
right available in those corners to take
those three so brook lopez
we need a bounce back and on the other
side of the court jay crowder
plays better on the road than he does at
home
in game three my guy went six for seven
for downtown so i'm looking at jay
crowder
looking at chris middleton looking at
drew holiday and i'm gonna sprinkle on a
brook lopez those are the four players
who i think
are going to be responsible for our
three by two parlay
g money who are the guys that you are
looking at to
uh to hit our 3x2 parlay in game six
cabbie they're shooters all over the
court you just named a few
we got bridges don't forget about cp3
booker
you said middleton you named drew
holland i mean they're shooters
all over people who are your guys though
g money which which guys are you gonna
give me seven dudes like
we getting the three by two multiple
times all right hold on hold on let me
get into these comments because you know
i am a man of the people
cabbie wants me to be specific so let me
let me go let me go be specific in these
comments cabbie
i'm giving away some hoodies right now
giving away some of these i got
brooke and brooke lopez and devin
oh devin
book oh i'm so sorry hey i'm hey i'm
over here
i'm like hold on bro i'm trying to do
the math too bro
this is live this is live this is live
right now so you guys
we got brooke and book lopez and devin
booker
shout out to um go blue you're walking
away with a hoodie uh i got
j321 it's an elimination game of course
holiday and booker shout out to you j321
you are walking away
with a hoodie as well uh
cabbie the the comments are jumping t
gibson two says
no wow bad vibes chris
chris struggles every game and no one
else on the bus is like that
would have to rely on sons players and
paul isn't
there right now wow t gibson came with
the vo with the bad vibes
uh but guess what i'm gonna send
goodbyes your way with the hoodie t
gibson shout out to you
you were walking away with a hoodie uh
cabbie
and aaron it is very apparent if you
guys were in the comments right now they
are literally
jumping with people saying yes to the
3x2 so that means we are as a family all
riding with the 3x2 you guys can put the
yes down there for me because you guys
know
i am riding with the 3x2 and i'm giving
out a pair of kicks
um cabbie should i do it now if you want
to
i also need to i also need to know your
players because i'm interested in a
little side action if you're if you're
uh oh my cabbie wants to know my players
i'm trying to give out
i'm trying to give out shoes cabbie all
right i got you
uh players i'm gonna go drew holliday
and d booker
there it is drew holiday d book let me
think about it
they're just gonna okay they're just
gonna be a part of one of the three by
twos either the first quarter or the
third quarter
do i need yeah yeah
here we go um giving out giving out 250
dollars right now giving out 250 dollars
in sneaker money
uh it's it's it's intense in these
comments it is intense in these comments
i got t-money
t-money 3004
t-money 3004 says crowder
and johnson crowder
and johnson for the 3x2 so shout out to
utmoney3004
you are walking away with 250 dollars
that's sneaky m johnson
cam johnson not a starter but uh hey who
knows
yeah maybe yeah maybe yeah maybe
so you had you had booker and and
holiday booker holiday cabbie that's
what i'm rocking with
side bet that that combination doesn't
hit
cyber
like if if holiday or booker aren't a
part of a three by two
so you're saying yes those guys and i'm
saying i'm saying no
all right skip five bet low 50 on it
low 50. i feel like i feel like the odds
are i feel like the eyes are off air and
i feel like i should get like five to
one
and like paddy should pay me fifty
dollars you know what i mean
because it's like what are the odds
these two players
that i name are going to make a three
pointer on the first one
two to one two to one i'll give you a
hundred and if they if they don't
if you know if they hit and if not then
send me 50. all right
what are the people in the comments do
you guys think i should take the bet or
should i not take the bet you guys
comment let me know cabbie i'll get back
to you
we'll get the show going and i'll get
back to you we gotta see what the people
think
please do in the last couple of shows on
twitter we asked you who was gonna win
the finals of ep the first time the
overwhelming response was
chris paul the next time we asked that
question on twitter the overwhelming
response
sorry response was giannis antetokounmpo
uh in the middle of game five see
cj mccullum dropped this on basketball
twitter about the mvp
the finals mvp conversation if the bucks
win the series
how many votes does midi chris middleton
get for finals mvp
robin serving and closing
so it's he just just dropped it in there
a ton
ton of responses and maybe he's on team
perkins he's been saying that
chris middleton is batman and giannis is
robin but anyway
here's here's our twitter poll the
updated odds for
finals mvp giannis overwhelming minus
430
d book uh plus 650 chris paul plus 700
so who is the best bet to win the finals
mvp heading into game six the best bet
greg have you changed your mind uh about
the finals of ep as we look at the
look here at the results giannis 48 of
the vote
devin booker 27 of the vote coming off
those two huge 40-point games
g-money where you at where do you stand
on finals mvp
cabbie uh i'm in the comments right now
and they are
back and forth about our bet i see a lot
of me take the bet i see a lot of people
say don't take the bet also see
caviar is finessing you right now greg
uh
i'm giving you two to one how am i
finessing one
uh the people in the car i'm just
repeating what they're saying in the
comments cabbie
uh but what i need you guys to do is get
in the comments and tell me
who is winning finals mvp and tell me
why who's the best bet to win finals mvp
please tell me why the commenter with
the best take is earning themselves 250
in sneaker money uh aaron
you like cp3 early on
how are you feeling about that now like
you just mentioned i had said after
games one and two to wait and get cp3 at
better value if the bucks were able to
put up some wins well guys now we
clearly have some value cp3 i don't know
what happened to him
after his finals debut at this point you
obviously wouldn't even want to bet
giannis
at this price minus 4 30. i think
giannis is deserving
of finals mvp if the bucks do win
tonight of course there is arguments
around chris middleton and that he
should actually win it but from a value
perspective i would take cp3 or devin
booker if you do think the suns can come
back tonight force at game seven
and potentially be able to win the title
but i just i can't bet on giannis that
minus 4 30 at this point
seven to one odds on chris paul is hella
juicy
uh going back to the the cj mccollum
tweet
this is um there's an interesting
argument here because
who do you value more the and i'm gonna
use a baseball analogy
the starting pitcher who takes you you
know first seven innings and then
there's a middle relief and then the
closer comes in at ninth
or so so in this case giannis is the
starting pitcher
and then chris middleton is the closer
the the comparison is closer to kobe and
shaq in the early 2000s where shaq
would dominate the game for three
quarters and then kobe would take over
in the fourth
it feels like in this series giannis is
dominating through three and a half
quarters
middleton sprinkled in there as well but
then middleton goes to work in those
last five minutes and hits mid-ranges
all over the court so
my personal take is santa takumpo after
game two so after the suns were up two
nothing in the series
bucks down 02. that's when i jumped in
and i got giannis at plus 450
uh to win mvp so i'm riding with giannis
and i would love to see him close it out
tonight
for uh personally like self for selfish
reasons
uh but the best bet i think is chris
paul
at seven to one to win finals mvp
g-money where do you stand
on this particular uh bet here best
value
finals mvp uh cabbie
aaron let me see where the people stands
uh
in the comments i got i got steve
jobless he got the giannis gif of
giannis dancing
and he says easy money easy money you
see yanis giggin right there
shout out to you steve jobless you were
walking away with the hoodie
i have uh
had a head of wp says giannis with those
two huge plays at the end of
the last two games is deserving of an
mvp
shout out to you heta wp you are walking
away
with a hoodie i got not zach levine says
d-book
been sanit since the series first
started he's going to drop 53 this game
and they win the next two
i'ma stop right there i'ma stop right
there because the question is who is the
best
bet for mvp not who's gonna actually win
it but the best bet for mvp
is absolutely devin booker do you not
see the value
do you not see the value he he has value
next to his name
plus 650 cabbie he's been absolutely
bawling this
series is not over let me repeat
this series cabbie is not
over so is that going to game seven it
might it just
might be you just said the series is not
over not just mine
we still have to play tonight's game
cabbie therefore
technically what i'm saying is correct
this series
is not over okay aaron
was the way that he was positioning it
like he's like he's confident that
there's going to be a game seven
well i feel like we kind of all have to
at this point just considering
that giannis is so far out we're kind of
assuming that
we yeah exactly thank you eric it's like
what's the best bet
the best bet is d-book he's been balling
plus 6.50
series isn't over cabbie are you betting
on the game seven
are you are you inside we're not you
wanna do another side bet that there
will or will not be a game
heavy in your side bet see the thing is
though cabbie we talked about scott
foster we talked about that already
so that's that's in the back actually
let me actually let me throw in this
stat
actually really quick quick only four
teams have ever bounced back
from an o2 deficit in the nba finals
plus miami heat were the last team
to win four straight after coming off an
o2 deficit that was in 2006.
yeah d wade's miami heat so it's been a
while book in the mid-range game
it's very hard to do so we are basically
here
are hey everybody in the comments saying
that the series is over they're saying
it's janice the series is over
i don't know i don't think it's over
we're gonna see we're gonna see shout
out to aaron and your stat
uh it's time hey cabbie i gotta give
away some shoes
okay put give away some shoes but i also
want you to put your money where your
mouth is
but go ahead give away some sneakers
kevin is a little hostile today with
these side bets
on on i need a little bit more action i
think is what i need i'm going to jump
into these player props right after the
show and just get get to the business
kevin also i need to win some money back
from greg true and you don't know this
aaron
but i've lost two or three bets to greg
so i'm kind of chasing
some of my money back i understand here
we go uh
let me see i got
i'm in the comments i am in the comments
joe cool joe cool
0-5 says jr holiday if it wasn't for him
and his defense
giannis wouldn't have even gotten that
game stealing alley-oop
he has stepped it up in every way that
is a great take but he is
not winning mvp but since
it was a good take and it was factual
jew holiday has been bawling he has been
putting the clamps on cp3
well you know he's been playing them
well uh
so i'm gonna give joe cool zero five
shout out to you you're walking away
with 250 dollars i'll get you some shoes
wow for a true holiday take okay well
done sir
um all right so we've just been talking
about uh chris paul and scott foster
here's an interesting
uh parallel when it comes to narratives
the logo the nba logo
is in the form of jerry west one of the
nba's 50 greatest players
he's known as mr clutch he went to the
nba finals
nine times in his career and he lost
eight
he's still known as mr klush now in this
era
chris paul is widely considered the
considered the most clutch player
of his generation but if things don't
play out
tonight if they if he doesn't carry
phoenix to a seventh game
will all those clutch performances be
forgotten that's like
this is one of the topics of of
narratives when we get into what we're
evaluating greatness these are some of
the storylines
that are at play so will chris paul
rewrite
history and carry his team to a game
seven
or might we consider him
more of a bust than clutch the question
is tonight
how many points is chris paul scoring
over under 21 and a half
g-money that is the line where do you
stand on this player prop
or do you need to check in with your
people before you give us your answer
uh i'm definitely have to check him with
my people i'm just confused that you
calling chris paul clutch when is he
in the regular season man he is a
team changer bro every team that chris
paul goes to their winning percentage
changes by like a hundred points i mean
he did it in
l.a he did it with the with use of
rockets he did it with the oklahoma city
thunder
and the and the phoenix suns were a
bubble team bro they didn't even
make it into the playing game last year
they won 26 games
and now they're in the finals two games
away from winning their first ever nba
championship
that and his his his uh clutch
stats which i don't have them in front
of me unfortunately but his his clutch
stats are like
uh otherworldly 50 60 70 up there with
your guy dame lillard who's from the bay
up in that range in the regular season
like i mean because
usually we see chris paul getting put
out by the golden state warriors year in
and year out
uh so as far as in this clutch i don't
know about
you know what i know you know what i do
so hold on i'm also we also got to give
chris paul
props for doing it with with in the
absence of a super team
unlike your golden state warriors he's
doing it with devin booker deandre ayton
giannis two there's no super team they
got rid of the super teams in la
both la and and in brooklyn so
salute to chris paul once again go ahead
about your golden state warriors though
aidan's number one pick d book superstar
status
i don't know cabbie anyway clutch i
wouldn't clutch i'm just having
a hard time calling them clutch but let
me let me do what we're here to do
get in the comments you guys get in the
comments and tell me if you think chris
paul's clutch or not
that's no they the commenters know chris
paul is clutch
i mean it's it's cabbie i i i just never
thought of chris paul
five seconds left we need a bucket chris
go get us a bucket that's clutch
aaron yeah i'm sorry i can't call chris
chris ball clutch come on now am i
serious
know it i know they played in the last
round but you've already forgotten about
his 41 point performance in game six
against clippers
zero turnovers he i think he had 11
11 13 assists zero
the clippers ever better are even a
better defensive team and he had
no turnovers i know but it only matters
because we're only playing the bucks
right now
guys chris paul's clutch okay the
audience will tell you in the comments
people are watching this i mean like you
guys are not if you don't think that
chris paul is clutch
people in the comments whole career
people in the comments is
he he he ain't clutch he impactful shout
out to you non
uh i lost their name but shout out to
you who just said that
uh you're walking away with the hoodie
you're giving someone who you forgot
they're phillips i'm trying to find him
out there oh not not naji
not naji uh shout out to you you're
walking away with a hoodie uh
all right so what what i need you guys
in the comments to do is let me one let
me know if he's clutch or not clutch
two let me know it's chris paul is he
gonna bring it back to houston is he
gonna
bring it back or is he gonna choke
tonight to let me know
basically let me know if he's going over
or under his points just let me know is
he is he going to show up and be
clutch like cabby says or is he uh going
to be
chris paul you guys have already
forgotten about game one in game two the
guy's
elite he's one aaron aaron where do you
stand 21 and a half points where are you
at with it
chris paul over under well he's
averaging 21 points in the series
only 15 when playing in milwaukee so
based on how he's been playing on the
road i'm definitely going under 21.5
points
plus he's only been able to put up more
than 21.5 points in
21 of 89 games this season so i'm taking
the ender
okay that's that's a great stat one in
every four and a half games that's
that's pretty legit look once putin
holds her made the
adjustment to put drew holliday on chris
paul guarding him
the the series has changed for chris
paul's offensive production jew holiday
this is the reason they sent uh like the
farm
to new orleans to get drew holiday three
draft picks in eric eric bledsoe's
contract and
and somebody else uh he wears them down
he picks him up at half court he fights
through screens
drew holliday is a great defender and
wearing down those 36
year old legs but this is a legacy game
this is a legacy series for chris paul
this is year 16.
so and i i mean i'm not a great i'm not
a big cliche guy
but his effort level he's going to leave
everything out there on the floor
tonight i'm saying he's going over
21 and a half points if you want to get
in on some live betting opportunities
bet chris paul points in the second half
he might have
four six eight in the first half but
then he picks it up in the second half
so
give me the over 21 and a half points
for cp3 tonight
g-money where do you stand on this
player prop cabbie i got finn sanity
five in the comments i had to save this
comment because it's such a good take
and it kind of talks to about your point
in chris ball being
clutch he says uh front runner for not
clutch his team has always been up in
the series
during a close out game
mean chris paul is known for being up
3-1 a lot of times
you know what i mean okay coming back in
la they're up 3-2 on your golden state
warriors but then he
injured his hamstring and then they
missed 27 shots in game seven wow that
wasn't his fault my guy was watching
from
all all i'm saying cabbie
clutch and people in the comments people
that are watching
clutch when i go to nba.com
go to nba.com and when stats you'll see
the numbers
when i think of the word clutch i think
of somebody who's going to give me a
bucket
at the end of the game do you guys
really think of chris paul as that is he
going to get you a bucket or is he going
to be a playmaker and make a play
boat he's a winning player so he could
do one or the other
he's going to get him he can create his
own shot get in space that mid-range
around the free-throw line or the
the right elbow those are his offices or
he could find somebody in the corner
like mikel bridges and his kd-13s
the yellow kd-13s the splash one from
the corner chris paul's a winning player
guys
let's not let's not blaspheme here okay
i got what
i got i got c x
c x p princ c x pinnix says
cp3 under with these reps impactful
but he has been turning the ball over
since
game three speaking of to aaron's point
shout out to you cx pinnick
uh you were walking away with a hoodie
aaron
i'm right there with you i mean since
they put my guy drew holiday
he's been impactful in forcing chris
ball
chris paul to make bad plays uh here we
go
i got one more hoodie in me cubby i just
want to give him one more hoodie
i got liam o'connell this is my guy
shout out to you liam liam
leah mulcano chris paul is not clutch
it's
hitting over but sons are taking an l
so he thinks chris paul is going to come
out there and try
to win this game for the sons but
eventually that they're going to take a
nail shout out to you liam you were
walking away with a hoodie
cabbie doug chris paul's not clutch the
the the people have spoken uh
i don't know what you see i'm rocking oh
i actually i got to give you guys my
pick
i'm rocking with the over i do think
chris paul is going to go out there and
try to win this game and
in order for him to do that he's going
to have to score so if sitting at minus
110 i like the over
but is he clutch i don't know this is
ridiculous this is
i mean you guys are you guys need to go
on chris paul youtube deep dives and
just watch him work
whether they're super cuts or or spend
some time on
basketballreference.com
cleaningtheglass.com
nba.com advanced stats you'll know that
chris paul gabby i watch
basketball i like god he's not
he's just knocked that yeah and he's not
what final verdict here he's just not a
clutch player
i don't really i'm not stashing you give
against the bucks that makes you think
that chris paul's clutching anyway it's
clutch he's being clutches i'm not
passing him the ball with five seconds
left yeah the last one yeah i'm not
passing
he's one of them they'll steal it away
they'll steal the ball away from him
he's like a little kid running around
out there
gonna be honest we don't have enough
time to continue this argument
which we were gonna we're gonna have to
have off camera off the stream
but listen thanks everybody for tapping
into the nba finals edition of the group
chat
live from the bleach report out thank
you for all the thousands of comments
and the hot takes none hotter than my
two co-hosts here that
chris paul is not clutch anyway that's
crazy remember what you learned
here tonight there are five players who
can possibly score 20 points tonight so
just take a second look at those scoring
player props like the chris paul over
under 21 and a half points uh the bucks
were down 16 in game five
and they came back to win so look again
at live scoring opportunities or live
betting opportunities
so much fun the 3x2 get on the 3x2
parlay
in the first half in the second half
lock in with fanduel sportsbook
and get that plus 410 odds boost
we have more show we have more kicks to
give away after the show g-money
uh we'll tap in with him uh be our
betting account
the br kicks um instagram account be our
betting instagram account
or the sports betting stream in the br
app those are three spots where you can
get a pair of free kicks
and if the series goes to game seven
tonight
if the series is extended to game seven
we'll be back on thursday for a final
edition
of the group chat how if not if the
miami bucks
handle business and they win in front of
the deer district and they're
anointed champions for the first time in
50 years
thank you so much for tapping in with
the group chat all season
we appreciate the support the comments
uh
and um all the vibes sunset vibes good
vibes
etc if you want a hoodie or sneakers
tonight we will dm you
enjoy game six uh g-money i want that
venmo right up
right away after the game if uh if the
3x2 doesn't hit
alongside aaron dolan from fanduel and
greg ivory
my name is cabbie richards we'll see you
guys later we are leaving the group chat
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you